hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal wann
und willkommen zum ersten video des
winterlichen wunderlandes welches auf
meinem kanal stattfinden wird und blogs
heißt aber heute starten die mit einem
nicht ganz normalen blog weil ich wollte
am ersten dezember anfang zu filmen und
das video kommt ja dann erst am zweiten
dezember und das vom zweiten kommt dann
erst am dritten aber welches video kommt
dann am ersten
deswegen dachte ich ich probiere mal
etwas aus was ich in letzter zeit auf
youtube gesucht habe es gibt nämlich
eine ganze community voll von hausfrauen
die ihre wohnungen oder häuser komplett
aufräumen und danach dekorieren und ich
weiß nicht woran es liegt aber diese
videos sind so unglaublich befriedigend
zu sehen wie sie die die tische sauber
wischen und dann machen sie etwas
weihnachtliches trafen nur denkst du sie
am morgen dekoriere den scheiß und das
will ich auch machen und lustigerweise
als in meiner schwiegermutter davon
erzählt haben also schwiegermama die hat
gesagt dass sie auch solche videos guckt
und dann ist mir erst so richtig bewusst
geworden das ist ein ding auf youtube
hausfrauen die ihre wohnung putzen und
putz tipps gegeben ist ein ding ich kann
euch keine tipps geben will ich jetzt
hier schon mal sagen
von mir gibt's kleine tipps nur ein
bisschen inspiration und eine kleine
hund oder durch weil ihr werdet ihr
jeden raum sehen und ihr seht was für
ein ferkel ich privat bin gestern war
ich dann noch einkaufen und hab die elle
decoration mitgenommen weil ich dachte
dass vielleicht auch eine gute
inspiration zeit kann oder mich einfach
zum aufräumen motivieren kann ich hab
kein ich hab keinen bock ich hab mich
die ganze zeit auf diesen tag so gefreut
bisher heute angekommen ist und dann
dachte ich mir so lehmann
ich will einfach nicht aufräumen wer hat
denn los aufzuräumen
ja ich gekostet 6 eur 52 ich hätte mir
erwartet winter glück wir schmücken das
haus den baum und den tisch die gäste
können kommen herrlich werdet ihr dieses
jahr gäste einladen zu euch ich bin noch
nicht sicher
da würde ich auch gerne leben ja ich
muss sagen das war die l war keine gute
idee
ich sehe einfach in der l nur orte wo
ich gerne leben würde aber niemals leben
werde
ja ich fühle mich jetzt mega inspiriert
seid ihr eigentlich leute die er jedes
jahr das gleiche aufstellen oder kauft
ihr euch immer neue designs und macht zu
themen weil in diesen dekorations videos
haben voll viele frauen gesagt so ja
letztes mal wie rot und grün und dieses
mal hatten wir alles weiß aber es
bedeutet ja dass man alles nochmal neu
holen muss und nicht nur das es ein
bisschen verschwendung ist für so
programm ist teuer
gestern schon wieder 60 70 euro
ausgegeben für deko okay leute blog tag
nummer 1 kann starben
ja das wär doch gründe und wir beginnen
mit unserer wäsche da ist es natürlich
super praktisch schon mal in einer
beziehung zusammenlebt dass man doppelt
so viel machen muss aber dafür macht ja
der partner auch die wäsche und am ende
kommt es bei null raus ja schön die ohne
hosen und socken sortieren und bei den
socken da ich würde mich jetzt gerade
interessieren legt ihr sie schon richtig
auf den wäscheständer damit ihr sie
schneller wieder runter nehmen können
weil das mache ich manchmal und ich
glaube das spart sogar wirklich zeit
aber
voll engagiert für sein
[Musik]
ja wäscheaufhängen ist auch super
spannend muss ich sagen da muss man
alles in die richtige schublade rein
machen und jetzt kommt auch der jetzt
kommt der wäscheständer eu und der
wäschekorb und jetzt fertigten schublade
weiter update ich habe mir sondern
gezogen
ich habe mir was anderes angezogen weil
ich das gefühl hatte dass ich in dieser
gruppen hose eine relativ wabbeligen
hintern hatte und ich das nie antun
wollte und jetzt beziehen das bett neu
also nur das bettlaken weil das schon
relativ lange her war seit ich das
gewechselt hat ich habe dieses
bockspringen bett geholt und liebe es
wirklich über alles nur dieser stoff ist
müssen und praktisch weil man den
ständig saugen muster sammelt sich diese
ganze staub und kann man halt nicht
einfach wegwischen
also ich lebe auch nach der logik dass
man nicht genug essen auf seinem bett
haben kann das sieht nämlich super
gemütlich und cosi aus das ist das
gleiche wort also quasi gemütlich ihr
wisst was ich meine
[Musik]
ja und so ein schlafzimmer kann man auch
unendliche langen aufräumen ich weiß
nicht wie es immer so unordentlich in
kriege aber
[Musik]
man muss auf jeden fall noch mal sagen
alle sachen über alles staub ich glaube
es nicht es ist wirklich so staubig und
wenn man nicht aufräumt dann merkt man
gar nicht wie also die unendlich ist
willkommen zu der kommode der schande
wie sie gerne nennen denn da liegt
wirklich alles drauf das ist ein bild
was uns ein obdachloser in london
verkauft hat also ich habe sie ihm
abgekauft für 10 pfund fand ich schön
und aufräumen ist wirklich einfach nur
dinge an seinem platz legen ist
irgendwie komisch dass man sich einfach
von anfang an machen kann
und jetzt wird die ganze sache noch mal
hier auch schön gewischt genau damit
alle bakterien und alles ja toll und man
kriegt oder zuschauer und den spiegel
auch noch mal saubermachen bin und
meinen tollen fenster sauger der es
wirklich extrem praktisch habe ich schon
erwähnt dass ich staub gewischt habe
hier waren nämlich viel staub drauf
homeserver rübergehen kommen ja wohl und
fertig war stolz auf dich vanessa den
tannenbaum hat ein 100 geholt und der so
weiß und schlicht und ich wollte die
deko meinem schlafzimmer ein bisschen
schlechter halten damit man dort zur
ruhe kommt bringt ja nichts wenn man es
aufräumt und damit dekoration zugeknallt
und auch die kommode der schande ist
nicht mehr die kommode der schande
sondern ein
ruhe oase mit drei sachen drauf einen
pass welt anbau und einem süßen
pflänzchen und das war's
[Musik]
und dann ist mir auch aufgefallen was
für ein schönes schlafzimmer ich
eigentlich hab also richtig gemütlich
schlafzimmers fertig und jetzt geht's an
den fluren kann sie nicht länger
versteckt halten
was los wenn die alte dich wieder
vielleicht hey leute
also falls ihn noch nicht kennt das ist
mein freund
[Musik]
im flur habe ich mich zuerst um die
jacken gekümmert das heißt alle sommer
und herbst jacken raus ich habe gerade 1
2346 pakete für nachbarn und dann war
der schuhschrank und die ablage
obendrauf dran und die ist wirklich so
unordentlich weil man einfach alles was
man in der hand hat oben drauflegt und
als ich dann alle schuhe runter genommen
habt ist mir inzwischen auch aufgefallen
dass ich glaube ich diesen schuhschrank
noch nie sauber gemacht habe ein tipp
hier von mir macht eure schuhschränke
sauber
[Musik]
outfit wechsel nummer 23
keine schnee matte weil das eignet sich
ganz gut
[Musik]
ja
und mit der kraft der videoschnitt
technik kann ich das wohnzimmer mit
einem klatschen saubermachen oder auch
nicht ich habe noch eine sache die ich
machen möchte die habe ich mir nämlich
so lange aufgehoben und ihnen muss ich
um tageslicht machen weil ich habe angst
vor der erde
es ist quasi ein mach deine scheiße tag
findet man macht es nur im januar glaub
ich hey ich glaub jetzt um die pflanzen
ich bin kein experte was grüne daumen
geschichten angeht aber ich liebe meine
pflanzen und deswegen kümmere ich mich
immer um sie und in diesem fall musste
ich sie umtopfen weil das wasser nicht
richtig ablaufen konnte weil diese töpfe
kein loch unten hatten
also habe ich so ein betonkopf geholt
und da ist mehr da rein gemacht die alte
erde von der pflanze abgeklopft und dann
die pflanze eingesetzt und das habe ich
auch mit der klein gemacht die hatte
schon richtig viele geschichten also
neuse und alles und ich kann sie einfach
nicht wegschmeißen ich kann pflanzen ich
das sind meine kinder irgendwo und um
die muss man sich kümmern
[Musik]
ich habe mir das aufräumen bisschen
leichter vorgestellt
ja ja ja ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich möchte menschen nur die menschen die
so denken und so was sehen wie du siehst
du lernst noch was dazu
[Musik]
obst im haus wie decken den tisch
tolle decke oder drittel der kaktus hat
mich geboxt aber bist du ich sehe dich
gewachsen
das wenn du sie fällst kriegst du es
nicht mehr vom spiel des fremde erde ist
nur fremd wenn der fremde sie nicht
[Musik]
okay so sie sind wir status mäßig das
ist schon relativ fertig die küche ist
auch gerade fertig essbereich auch
relativ fertig jetzt haben wir noch
nicht umgestellt naja die steht es bei
mir im zimmer
jetzt kommt noch dieses regal zurück ich
habe leute ich kann nicht mehr
aber ich bin relativ zufrieden
ich merke dass ich mit meinen möbeln
nicht ganz zufrieden bin also die stühle
weil ich schon lange lange wechseln bzw
2 ja das wird es aber lange nicht
passieren ich sags ganz lange und dann
passiert es doch nicht
[Musik]
so schön oder com kann man auf jeden
fall akzeptieren in seinem leben immer
noch tag 1 zu guter letzt habe ich dann
noch eine lichterkette an die
fensterfront angebracht und die sieht
natürlich auch für die aus und das war's
mit meinem ersten video im blog mit ja
ich hab euch jetzt gefallen und bis
morgen sieht man das gar nicht
doch womit wir machen